now David Cameron will announce new
measures later to prevent young people
being radicalized into terrorism thought
700 potential extremists have made the
trip from the UK to Syria there half of
those may have returned the new
proposals will see an extension of
powers were passports withdrawn from
young people at risk of traveling abroad
to join extremist groups such as
self-styled Islamic state there'll be
bans on radical preachers posting
material online anyone with a conviction
or civil order for terrorist or
extremist activity will also be
automatically barred from working with
children and vulnerable people well the
Home Secretary Theresa May told sky news
this morning that it's time to step up
the fight against what she described as
extremist propaganda we would say in
future that somebody who's been
convicted of a terrorism offense at act
offenses it's call that relates to the
act under which the which sets out
terrorism offenses would be
automatically barred from working with
children or vulnerable adults that is
just one measure in what is a very
wide-ranging counter extremism strategy
that we're launching today and we're
launching that because we do face an
unprecedented threat from extremism
groups like ISIL can put their can send
through the internet their message of
their perverted message of hatred into
family homes we see men and women and
indeed whole family's going out to Syria
I think that shows us that we need to
step up our action to counter extremism
and we need to do more to counter the
message of extremism and counter that
message of extremism across the broad
we've seen last week for example
significant Rises and reported hate
crimes and so what the strategy talks
about is dealing with extremism of all
sorts o Islamist extremism but also
neo-nazi extremism those who are
promoting messages of hatred and
division in our communities we need to
deal with that too and today is a
recognition that there is more that we
need to do in order to counter these
messages of hatred these messages of
division that the extremists are
promoting so we want to counter the
extremist ideology but we also want to
work with communities to promote
mainstream voices and to build more
cohesive
munities so it's very much looking at I
I've I've seen from the work that I've
done already the excellent work that is
being done by community groups around
the country i was in birmingham a few
weeks ago meeting groups who are
actually out there countering extremism
of all sorts on our streets and i was
present last week when the Prime
Minister chaired a a community
engagement forum where he bought people
from communities from groups who were
actually doing this work mainstream
voices who are countering the extremist
ideology but also building up cohesion
in their communities well it's question
we posed before is David Cameron and his
government fighting extremism in the
right way what is the right way is there
a right way Jordan is actors discuss at
this morning after I strap is a
consultant fellow at the Royal United
Services Institute and duly Hussein
who's deputy editor of the British
Muslim news website five pillars
gentleman oh good morning to both of you
and thanks for coming in after can start
with you is there such a thing as a
right way to fight extremism and we seem
to have had numerous announcements from
the Prime Minister the Home Secretary d
radicalization programs no end of them
what's it doing what achieving well it's
a very good question and there is no
single silver bullet so to speak to to
fight extremism and this this new range
of measures indicates that the measures
we've put in place haven't addressed the
problem and the point is that you can't
prevent extremism you can only limit it
you can only limit its effect in its
scope the the main drivers of extremism
aren't addressed through this bill nor
can they be addressed through this bill
the two things that drive extremism one
is the extremists perception of Western
foreign policy and also Muslim countries
regime types the second thing that
inspires them is the concept of success
and success has demonstrated a decade
and a half ago by Al Qaeda in a very
spectacular fashion and success is
demonstrated by da Shore ISIL just a
year ago in the spectacular way in which
it grabbed territory in Iraq having
dominated Syria
let's just develop that point if we can
this this idea that ISIL have got a
story to tell and a story to sell I mean
there's a mileage in that isn't isn't
that because the government seems to
want to almost present being interested
in extremism some sort of mental
condition them and then they are liking
it to be in a pedophile today but go
online talk to people who know what
they're talking about on this subject
and you quickly become aware that i
still have got a manifesto a theological
stroke political manifesto for changing
the world you may not like it i may not
like it many many people what the
government doesn't like it but it's a
coherent and in the eyes of those people
want to perpetrate it logical manifest
overpower it is indeed but my biggest
concern over the count extremism policy
which has announced today is that the
fishing net to actually prosecute
so-called islamist extremists is so far
and wide that it is a genuine threat
that you may end up criminalizing muslim
organisations speakers are inherently
nonviolent have our polls to ISIL and
that's my main concern because you've
got this this word extreme exact which
is it's a very broad is a very broad
term and it's very vey but my other
concern is it's a very dangerous prophet
going down where a secular state now
starts interfering on religious affairs
and doctrines especially if it's
nonviolent arm of the position that the
perceived threat of islamist extremism
should be debated should be dialogue and
if if mr. cameras amidst resumes
worldview and ideology and big society
they're so confidently then let it be
debated as soon as you start silencing
dissent this is a very dangerous path
because of so we know that we have you
start to suppress ideas they'll often go
underground i mean these ideas are
underground enough as it is online
rather than be presented in the full
glare of you know the mass media but you
if you make it illegal to express an
opinion which other people may hold to
be offensive in terms of you know
Islamism then you force it even deeper
underground when you well you might do
but that's a balance you have to strike
between forcing things to an underground
level and allowing them to have
credibility and influence people know we
already do this in principle when it
comes to racism
anti-semitism it comes to hate speech
all of these things dili is absolutely
right very difficult to define and this
is where we need to look to the law and
in how it defines these terms how it
interprets these terms whether it can
interpret them in the spirit of the law
rather than the letter of the law and so
it really comes down to how the law is
applied rather than how it could be
applied how many people delete in your
view are going to be ringing up the
local police station saying look I've
just heard the Prime Minister's
announced that it's now possible for me
as a parent of a teenager who may be
susceptible to the influences of
Islamism I can have his or her passport
taken away he or her is 17 and I don't
want them to travel to Syria so take
away their passport that's one of the
proposals today how many people do you
think realistically will be making that
call I don't think I can substantiate
that with an actual number but a handful
hundreds I don't think many ruled
because i think the muslim community are
worried that they are being singled out
and we're a genuine a wavering towards
finding out your Islamic identity or
more about the political aspects of
Islam will then be conflated and
misconstrued with being sympathizers for
ISIL or wanted to travel to Syria and
again it's very important that we
differentiate between those who pose an
actual physical threat of terrorism and
violent criminality and those who have
an ideological nonviolent perspective to
snow hey here we come here we come to
the absolute rubbed only because after
as you knows i'm sure people thought the
intelligence community will tell you
that it's deciding at what point
somebody who's espousing extremist views
becomes becomes violent and they can't
wait sometimes until that person commits
an act or prepares to commit an act
they've got to a judge in the best way
they possibly can that somebody's
looking like they're going down a
particular track and intervening yes and
that's a problem that the intelligence
services and more importantly the police
have to face is at what point do they
disrupt a plot that they can see coming
along but they don't actually have
physical evidence
it may be too late to wait for that
evidence and they they they do the best
they can in terms of disrupting but the
problem of course is the ideas that
inspire people to act and the know how
to act to cause harm to innocent people
so I think that that is an issue and I
think the point I think that we should
think about and until he has made a
comment which we all fall into very now
every now then that is the Islamic the
Muslim community there's no so you can
speak for something yeah that's kind of
the candy corn there are a set of
beliefs and views which I think there is
a general consensus but yes you're right
to find a single representative Muslim
community is difficult and this is why
mr. Cameron's community engagement forum
which he met with last week the MCV will
not include the previous British Muslim
umbrella organization was not included
so it raises concerns as to who exactly
mr. cameron is liaison corresponding
with to tackle this issue of extreme so
I'll cut you off midstream there you
just gonna finish your point but my
point was simply this that there is no
singular community but the other point
that I think we must remember is that if
there is I if there are victims
internationally of these people eighteen
ninety percent of their victims their
targets dices targets ISIL targets are
Al Qaeda's victims have been Muslims and
so a great many Muslims that I come
across find these people far more
dangerous far more offensive than
non-muslims because they have hijacked
their faith which they understand to be
a peaceful faith and they're using that
faith not just to target Muslims but to
to sully the reputation of Islam be part
of the good just just put this thought
in your head part of the government's
pictures to say look there's an online
and you admitted some sure there is this
massive online debate going on the
government says we need to be UK
government needs to be much more
involved in that debate now in holding
up a mirror to people who are thinking
about embracing hardline Islam is Amanda
been going to serious stroke Iraq and
part of what you got to do is show them
actually like all utopian vision
the reality is not up there with the
dream yeah that actually is pretty grim
the trains don't run on time yeah etc
etc etc but but that requires debate and
dialogue not shutting down dissent my
issue here is the ideology the thinking
which underpins such policies and that
is this empirically and substantiate
academically flawed conveyor belt theory
to court sir peter fahy from 18 months
ago he said why is it left to the police
to define or root out who the extremists
up he fears that we may be slowly moving
towards a police state can you have it
both ways though can you circumscribe
certain debates about Islam by saying
don't like that we're going to call that
Islamic for Islam a phobic well that's
an issue we need to have a fact-based
approach ultimately that's what it is
you need to have a [ __ ] break based upon
was no residual we must not have a
situation where it becomes where debate
about you know tough debate about where
Islam's going is precluded the fear have
been called an Islamophobe well we need
to be very clear about the definition
Islam for an Islamophobe is someone who
has an inherent irrational fear and an
aggression against Islam or Muslims I
think that's quite clear I mean I think
to have a robust discussion about Islam
is political aspects who it represents
who it doesn't represent its differences
between the so-called Islamic state or
ISIL that needs to take place all I'm
asking for is a fact based approach to
tackling extremism not a knee-jerk
reaction whereby the fishing net
criminalizes large strains of the Muslim
community Delhi's talking about a
fishing net so let's talk about a
shotgun because sometimes it was like
this is this policy as a shotgun to
shoot a wasp in the sense that you've
got numbers which are relatively small
the ones in our graphic was suggesting
700 people have traveled from the UK to
Syria stroke Iraq don't know how true
those figures are but it feels like an
awfully small number producing an
enormous government effort yes and
that's the nature of terrorism when you
look at terrorist victims of terrorism
they're tiny compared to road traffic
accidents and so on I'm afraid that is
the problem that we have is that people
particularly in democratic societies
have an irrational fear of terrorism so
when dili talks about having a
national debate the problem is this is
not a rational subject and so you will
have this issue the problem is that
governments have learnt that the
tolerance that people have particularly
damage democratic states for terrorist
acts is very low and so in response to
this threat tiny as it is they need to
be seen to be acting the area that I
think that we should ask our governments
to deal with all the root causes which
are to do with foreign policy but also
regime types and are also to do with the
attraction that these people present not
just in their world cool because his
move don't we there was a time ten years
ago where one of the causes of Islamist
extremism was poverty no he's like
nobody buys everything what was it ah
911 I was a young lad back then yeah
that's an appropriate point delete this
to make daily insane after last draft
explains very much indeed it's